بدأت ووكر ورفاقها حقًا بدافع
إحباطاتي الخاصة لعدم
امتلاك منتجات يمكنني استخدامها وعدم وجود
علامات تجارية تتحدث معي لمدة 15 عامًا ،
لم أتمكن من استخدام ماكينات الحلاقة متعددة الشفرات ،
تلك الأشياء تقص الشعر تحت
بشرتي وإذا  لديك شعر مجعد وهو ما
أفعله ، سيعود شعرك إلى بشرتك
، وتهيج الحلاقة و نتوءات الحلاقة هي
مشكلة كبيرة وقد أرسلني في هذه
الرحلة للعثور على المنتجات التي نجحت بالفعل
ومفهوم الحلاقة ذات الشفرة الواحدة
كان أول شيء
نجح بالفعل  بالنسبة لي للمساعدة في التخفيف من
أي مشاكل تتعلق بتهيج
الحلاقة أو مطبات الحلاقة ، وكنت أعرف على الفور أن
لدينا شيئًا مميزًا جدًا لـ 80٪
من الرجال والنساء السود الذين يعانون من
هذه المشكلة و 30٪ من أي شخص آخر ، نعم
ترى كيف يكون هذا  هي منطقة سهلة
أود التفكير فيها كعلامة تجارية للعناية بالبشرة
باستخدام أدوات الحلاقة لإصلاح مشكلة العناية بالبشرة ، كانت
شفرات الحلاقة ذات الشفرة الواحدة
منتشرة منذ أكثر من مائة عام
في الواقع بدأ سوق الحلاقة بها
شفرات حلاقة أحادية الحافة مزدوجة الأمان ،
لا يوجد شيء خاطئ في هذه
العملية بشفرة واحدة ، فهي تقطع
مستوى الشعر مع الجلد
ليس تحته مثل الكثير من ماكينات الحلاقة متعددة الشفرات ، قم
بقطع واحد نظيف ، لذلك لا يوجد سحب أو
شد مثل الكثير من  تقوم ماكينات الحلاقة متعددة الشفرات
بذلك ، فهذه هي الطريقة الصحيحة
لحلاقة علامتنا التجارية الأولى ، حيث أطلقنا
علامة تجارية ثانية تسمى شكل في صيف
العام الماضي ، وسنستمر في
فعل نفس الأشياء التي كنا
نقوم بها في الماضي  خمس سنوات من حل
المشكلات الحادة من خلال
سرد القصص الأصيل بمنتج يعمل
بتصميم جميل ، أنت تعلم أن الصيغة
تعمل في كل مرة ، فلماذا يجب أن
نتوقف ، أعتقد أن هناك أهمية بالنسبة
لي لإظهار أن اللون الأسود هو الثقافة السوداء الجميلة التي
أعتقد أنها تدفع
الثقافة الأمريكية  الأمر الذي يقود إلى
الخطأ الثقافي العالمي ، هل هناك مثل النسبة المثالية
التي تمثلها وما تحدثنا
عنه واتساق القيم
الذي يتسم بالاتساق في الرسالة التي تتسم
بالاتساق في  ebration هو أحد
الأشياء التي تميزنا عن الآخرين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]